16. Aproximadamente han transcurrido desde el
comienzo de la invasión rusa de Ucrania 16 meses.
16 meses desde que prácticamente
un desconocido, Volodímir Zelensky,
se convirtió en uno de los principales
protagonistas de la actualidad internacional.
El presidente de Ucrania es ya todo un
símbolo de la resistencia de Ucrania ante
los ataques del Kremlin. Y han sido 16
meses en los que Zelensky se ha dedicado
a pedir ayuda por activa y por pasivo.
De hecho, una de las claves que explican
la admirable resistencia de Ucrania ha
sido el continuo suministro de equipos
militares por parte de Occidente.
Pues bien, en mayo Kiev dio un paso
más hacia la última de sus grandes peticiones.
Doy la bienvenida a la decisión histórica de
Estados Unidos y su presidente de apoyar
una coalición internacional de aviones
de combate. Esto mejorará enormemente
nuestro ejército en el cielo. Cuento con
discutir la implementación práctica de esta
decisión en la cumbre del #G7 en Hiroshima.)
Coalición internacional de aviones
de combate. Ucrania lleva pidiéndolos
desde el comienzo de la invasión,
ya que fuerza aérea de Ucrania es
muy limitada. De herencia soviética es,
además, muy escasa en número de aviones.
Hasta el momento la aportación de Occidente
se ha limitado a unos 30 MiG-29 procedentes
de Polonia y Eslovaquia, importantes pero
totalmente insuficientes a juicio de Kiev.
Zelensky siempre ha insistido en que necesitan
los F-16 de fabricación estadounidense. Pero Biden
mostró varias muchas reticencias a suministrarlos.
Sin embargo, amigos, ahora algo ha cambiado.
A finales del mes de mayo, en
Hiroshima, en la cumbre del G-7,
el presidente de Estados Unidos dio por fin
buenas noticias al presidente ucraniano.
Hasta ahora Occidente consideraba
que Ucrania no necesitaba aviones de
combate para defenderse de Rusia. Ahora, sin
embargo, han cambiado de opinión… Claro que,
esperad un momento, porque los F-16
no van a llegar de un día para otro.
Hay muchas cuestiones que aún
están, nunca mejor dicho, el aire.
Cuestiones cuya resolución requerirá de
por lo menos unos cuantos meses. Así que
la pregunta es ¿Cómo ha sido el desempeño de las
fuerzas aéreas de Ucrania hasta el momento? ¿Qué
cambio puede suponer en el curso de la guerra
que Kiev disponga de un avión como el F-16?
¿De dónde van a salir los F-16 destinados a
las fuerzas aéreas ucranianas? Hoy vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero
antes… Vamos a ver un poco de historia.
T1(¡ME ESTOY QUEDANDO SIN SAMs, TÍO SAM!)
Hasta el momento la guerra de Ucrania
puede dividirse en 4 fases. La primera
se corresponde con los dos primeros meses.
Muchos recordaréis cómo al principio Rusia
se lanzó rápidamente sobre Kiev para
acabar con el Gobierno de Zelensky.
El Kremlin fracasó. Tuvo más éxito en el sur y
en el este de Ucrania, donde sus tropas sí que
lograron protagonizar importantes avances.
La aviación rusa se dedicó a bombardear las
principales defensas de Ucrania contra los ataques
aéreos, como los radares o algunos aeródromos.
Por fortuna, para Kiev, la inteligencia
estadounidense hizo bien su trabajo e
informó con horas de antelación del ataque
ruso. Eso le permitió a Ucrania dispersar
sus equipos para así minimizar daños. Fue
una jugada decisiva ya que así pudo salvar
de los primeros ataques de la invasión,
aviones, helicópteros y drones armados
que luego utilizó para atacar las columnas
rusas que avanzaban confiadas hacia Kiev.
La tan esperada superioridad del
Ejército ruso no se materializó
sobre el terreno. Y para sorpresa de casi
todos, tampoco en el aire, porque, amigos,
adentrarse en los cielos ucranianos conlleva
riesgos muchos añadidos para los rusos. Fijaos.
(La defensa aérea era clave para las fuerzas
armadas soviéticas. Esto significa que tanto
Rusia como Ucrania heredaron sistemas de
defensa aérea grandes y fuertes. De hecho,
Ucrania tenía la segunda densidad más alta
de este tipo de sistemas de toda Europa,
seguramente solo sup erada por Rusia. A esto
hay que añadir los MANPADS, los sistemas de
defensa antiaérea portátil, como los Igla y los
Stinger, que los ucranianos han logrado tener en
grandes números. Todo ello causó perdidas más
que significativas para la fuerza área Rusa,
hizo que de facto las hordas de Putin no pudieran
hacerse con el control pleno del espacio aéreo.)
Amigos, al comenzar su invasión, Rusia no
logró acabar con las defensas aéreas de
Ucrania. Eso supuso un duro golpe para sus planes.
Posteriormente, entre abril y agosto de 2022,
el Kremlin centró su ofensiva en la región del
Donbass. Y luego la tercera fase de la guerra
se inició con la contraofensiva
de Ucrania en el verano del 22.
Las tropas de Kiev lograron importantes
avances hasta noviembre con el apoyo,
precisamente, de su fuerza aérea. La fuerza
aérea que Rusia no consiguió destruir.
Esto supuso que se reanudaran los
escarceos entre aviones de ambos bandos.
Por su parte, Rusia aumentó sus ataques
con misiles sobre Ucrania. Sin embargo,
hasta la actual contraofensiva ucraniana, la
guerra estuvo completamente estancada entre
diciembre y junio. Durante esta cuarta fase,
Rusia ha seguido apostando por agotar con sus
misiles y drones los recursos de Ucrania para
la lucha antiaérea. Agotar los llamados SAMs.
(SAM es un acrónimo que significa surface to
air missile, es decir, misiles tierra-aire.
Ucrania disponía de un auténtico arsenal de SAMs
de la era soviética que ha ido disminuyendo con
el curso de la guerra. Y aunque lleguen sistemas
de defensa antiaérea suministrados por Occidente,
su integración con el resto de equipos
de los que dispone Ucrania lleva tiempo.)
Durante meses Zelensky estuvo reclamando
a Occidente lo mejor de sus inventarios:
tanques Abrams, y misiles Patriot, uno
de los sistemas de defensa antiaérea
más sofisticados del mundo.
No tuvo éxito por un tiempo.
Pero claro, si volar sobre
Ucrania fuera menos peligroso,
Rusia podría lograr la superioridad aérea.
Entonces se esfumarían prácticamente todas
posibilidades de que Ucrania reconquistara
su territorio. Así que, llegado este momento,
como decimos en VisualPolitik, fue dicho y hecho.
(Estados Unidos enviará a Ucrania sistemas de
misiles Patriot y tanques más rápido
de lo planeado originalmente. CNN)
Pues bien, obtenidos los Abrams,
los Leopards y los Patriot,
Zelensky retomó otra de sus
grandes peticiones: los cazas F-16.
Ya os hemos contado que Biden acaba
de dar luz verde a que empiece el
entrenamiento de los pilotos ucranianos
en este tipo de aviones. Sin embargo,
amigos, no hace tanto que el propio Biden
negó que Ucrania necesitara F-16. Mirad,
por ejemplo, esta entrevista en ABC
News del pasado febrero de 2023.
Y ahora, más de uno estará
pensando, pero a ver Enrique,
si la guerra de Ucrania ha estado estancada
durante tantos meses. ¿Qué diantres ha pasado
para que en apenas 3 meses la Casa
Blanca cambie de opinión? Pues bien,
a principios de abril se filtraron unas
informaciones del Pentágono que indicaban
que el equilibrio en los cielos de Ucrania estaba
a punto de romperse a favor de Rusia. Fijaos.
(Ucrania puede quedarse sin
defensas aéreas en mayo,
advierten documentos filtrados del Pentágono. WSJ)
Desde que empezaron a circular este tipo de
noticias, en Occidente hubo de repente división
de opiniones sobre qué hacer al respecto. Algunos
argumentan que Ucrania necesitan más defensas
aéreas del estilo de los Patriots o los NASAM
que ya estaban suministrando Estados Unidos y
otros países. Pero también ha crecido el número
de los que creen que es urgente proporcionar a
Kiev aviones de combate. Y la pregunta es, ¿Qué
puede significar exactamente la llegada de F-16
a Ucrania? Pues bein, ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
T2(TOP GUN)
Acaba de comenzar el verano y Ucrania
todavía no se ha quedado sin defensas
aéreas gracias a Occidente. Pero la
presión rusa continúa. Y si los SAMs,
los misiles tierra-aire se agotan, los aviones
rusos tendrían vía libre para bombardear Ucrania.
E incluso si estas armas comienzan a escasear,
el Gobierno de Zelensky tendría que elegir entre
proteger las ciudades, las infraestructuras, las
bases militares o las tropas desplegadas en el
frente. En teoría, los aviones de combate pueden
sustituir a las defensas aéreas terrestres para
derribar aviones enemigos, drones y misiles de
crucero. Eso es lo que ha estado haciendo hasta
ahora con sus aviones. Sin embargo, todo indica
que a Ucrania le están empezando a pasar factura
los 16 meses de conflicto, según datos ofrecidos
por el general estadounidense James Hecker.
(Ucrania ha perdido 60 aviones y ha derribado
70 en la invasión rusa, según Hecker)
A priori uno puede pensar:
bueno, pues no está mal,
¿no? Tampoco parecen tantos aviones
perdidos y ha derribado más.
Pero claro, el problema es que esos 60 aviones
de combate perdidos son ni más ni menos que el
40% de la aviación ucraniana de antes de la
guerra. A Ucrania solo le quedan alrededor
de 80 aviones frente a los casi 500 que el
Kremlin tiene asignados a este conflicto.
Y esperad un momento, porque además de
una abrumadora superioridad numérica,
la aviación rusa dispone también de mejores
radares y municiones con mayor alcance.
Ahora bien, como han fracasado en eliminar las
defensas aéreas de Ucrania, los aviones rusos se
ven obligados a disparar misiles o lanzar
bombas desde una distancia considerable,
lo que reduce mucho su efectividad. [Y
no olvidéis que hablamos de armas rusas]
Pero, el Kremlin también está utilizando
drones armados. Muchos son los famosos
Shahed-136 iraníes, que está matando dos pájaros
de un tiro: los SAMs de Ucrania y la capacidad
económica de Kiev para afrontar la guerra:
(Fabricar los drones iraníes cuesta tan
solo 20.000 dólares pero derribarlos
se dispara hasta los 500.000 dólares,
lo que supone una preocupación creciente en
Ucrania, según un informe. BusinessInsider)
Esto por no hablar de los Patriot. Lanzar
solo uno de estos misiles puede costar
hasta 4 millones de dólares,
un auténtico pastizal. Vamos,
es que lanzar 40 Patriot puede llegar
a equivaler a 160 millones. Una locura.
Como os podéis imaginar, este ritmo de
gasto no hay economía que lo aguante… Salvo,
claro está, que seas el Tío Sam. Así
que la opción de utilizar cazas para
neutralizar los ataques aéreos parece
bastante razonable. El problema de
la aviación de Ucrania es que sus
radares se han quedado obsoletos.
Kiev dispone de MiG-29 y Su-27 de la era
soviética. Y Polonia y Eslovaquia le han
dado más MiG-29. Pero llegado el momento,
estos aviones no tienen capacidad de hacer
frente a la aviación rusa. Ucrania necesita
una flota nueva. Justo aquí es donde cobra
protagonismo el F-16. Estamos hablando
de la columna vertebral de las fuerzas
aéreas de la OTAN durante los últimos
40 años. Su llegada complementaría las
defensas antiaéreas de Ucrania ya que
les aportaría algo nuevo: movilidad.
(Los cazas pueden proteger diferentes objetivos
al moverse rápidamente por un área. Además,
debido a la curvatura de la Tierra, los
radares de los aviones pueden ver objetos
voladores a distancias más largas que los
radares terrestres, una ventaja a la que hay
que añadir que los radares de los F-16 tienen
mayor capacidad que los de los cazas MiG-29.)
La formación de pilotos ucranianos para los
F-16 no será ningún problema. Ucrania tiene
más pilotos que aviones, así que Kiev ha
hecho una lista de hasta 50 pilotos que ya
están disponibles para comenzar a entrenarse
con el F-16. De esta forma, estos pilotos,
podrían estar preparados en unos meses y estar
operativos antes de finales de año. Sin embargo,
amigos, todavía existen algunas dudas…
Una es que los F-16 necesitan pistas
largas y lisas para despegar. Y claro,
en el Kremlin también lo saben. Mirad.
(Rusia lanza un ataque con misiles contra
objetivos en los aeródromos militares de Ucrania)
Una alternativa sería utilizar aeródromos
dispersos e improvisados. Estos podrían
ser más numerosos y más difíciles de
encontrar para los rusos. Pero claro,
las pistas serían más cortas y rugosas. O
en otras palabras, mucho más peligrosas.
Así que es cierto que Ucrania ahora mismo tiene un
problema con las pistas. Un argumento que refuerza
a los que defienden que necesita más artillería,
blindados y SAMs que cazas. Algunos también temen
que proporcionar el F-16 a Ucrania suponga una
escalada del conflicto. Algo que a descartado el
propio Biden, que asegura que el F-16 solo servirá
para defender a Ucrania, no para atacar a Rusia.
A ver, estamos hablando de un avión que está
operativo desde el año 1978, el mismo año en
el que se estrenaba Grease en los cines. Así que
no, los F-16 no son precisamente el último hito de
la aviación y no parece que su llegada a Ucrania
vaya a desatar el apocalipsis nuclear. Además,
la Casa Blanca ha sido muy hábil. Al utilizar
la cumbre del G7 para hacer estos anuncios,
Biden vinculó a sus aliados con
esta decisión. Y aquí es donde
surge la coalición internacional de aviones de
combate. ¿En qué se va a traducir? Pues… Atentos
T3(EL ESCUDO AÉREO UCRANIANO)
El impulso dado por Estados Unidos a la coalición
de aviones de combate es decisivo en la tanto en
cuanto se necesita el OK de Washington a la
exportación de cualquier caza F-16 a Ucrania,
aunque esos cazas pertenezcan ahora a otros
países. La coalición agrupa a varios países
europeos y aunque aún no tiene una denominación
oficial, Zelensky ha lanzado su propia propuesta.
Y oye, Marvel no lo hubiera hecho mejor.
(La coalición de aviones de combate. La
reunión con los líderes de los países europeos.
Hablamos de temas relacionados con el inicio de
la formación de pilotos ucranianos
en F-16 y otros tipos de aeronaves.
Acordamos continuar trabajando hacia una decisión
oficial para crear la coalición de aviones de
combate Ukrainian Sky Shield.Volodímir Zelenski)
Por otro tipo de aeronaves, Zelensky probablemente
se refiere a los Gripen suecos. Suecia
dispone de alrededor de un centenar,
pero hasta que no entré definitivamente
no podrá deshacerse de ninguno.
En cambio, se han construido más de 4.600 F-16
desde que comenzó su producción en los años 70.
Algunos todavía se están construyendo en
Carolina del Sur y Estados Unidos planea
mantener operativos dos décadas más sus modelos
más nuevos. Pero hay países que tienen pensado
reemplazarlos en cuanto les lleguen los nuevos
F-35. Así que acostumbraros a noticias como esta.
Es probable que los Países
Bajos envíen F-16 a Ucrania
después del entrenamiento de pilotos. Bloomberg)
Países Bajos es uno de los principales
impulsores de Ukranian Sky Shield. También
Reino Unido, pero no tiene F-16. Una opción es que
Londres los compre a otros países
y luego se los regale a Ucrania.
Sea como sea, proporcionar F-16 va
a suponer para los aliados un nuevo
esfuerzo económico importante. Para que
os hagais una idea, estos son los cálculos
ofrecidos por Colin Kahl, subsecretario
estadounidense de Política de Defensa.
Luego también hay otros países europeos que serán
claves para el Ukranian Sky Shield. Por ejemplo,
todo indica que el mantenimiento de los
F-16 podría realizarse inicialmente en
Polonia y Rumanía, países fronterizos con
Ucrania que ya utilizan este tipo de cazas.
Incluso Rumanía ha cobrado un protagonismo
especial en las últimas semanas. Mirad:
(Occidente mira a Rumania como posible lugar
de entrenamiento en F-16 para
pilotos ucranianos. Politico)
No hay que olvidar que tanto Polonia como
Rumanía son países miembros de la OTAN. Que
vayan a hacer en su territorio el entrenamiento
y, sobre todo, el mantenimiento de los F-16
significa que a priori permanecerán lejos
del alcance de los misiles rusos. Algo que
seguramente no agradará al Kremlin. De momento
Putin ya ha lanzado sus habituales amenazas.
De momento parece que Putin estará más ocupado
lidiando con Prigozhin y los Wagner. Además,
quedan bastantes meses para ver F-16 en
Ucrania. Quizás no lleguen hasta 2024.
Veremos. Pero enviar aviones de combate lanza
a Rusia un serio mensaje sobre el compromiso
de Occidente a largo plazo en la defensa de
Ucrania. Y ahora la pregunta es para vosotros:
¿Pensáis que los F-16 serán decisivos para
derrotar a Rusia? ¿Creéis que estos cazas
pueden provocar una escalada del conflicto? Podéis
dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Mientras tanto, no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas. Así que suscribíos
al canal para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones. Si os ha gustado este vídeo,
dadle a LIKE y nos vemos en el
próximo. ¡Un abrazo y hasta pronto!